they are ready for football indeed in
Chicago as here guys get set to do
battle with the Indianapolis Colts
despite some missteps in its new story
mode the refined on the field action and
the introduction of exciting new
x-factor and superstar abilities makes
Madden 20 a standout success the game
faithfully captures the essence of the
NFL experience it makes it fun and
rewarding to complete all manner of
different plays again and again a big
introduction for Madden NFL 20 is the
new story mode QB one face to the
franchise unlike the long shot mode from
previous games QB 1 lets you create an
entirely unique football star and guide
them through the final stages of the
college career and into the NFL yes
that's right college football from EA
Sports is finally back but the college
football elements within Madden 20 are
not very significant and are limited to
the single player mode exclusively as
for what is there there are 10 schools
to choose from including heavyweights
like Florida Oklahoma Texas and Clemson
it's a treat to see fully licensed
college football teams complete with
true-to-life jerseys logos stadiums and
marching band songs but the gameplay
experience in reality is limited to two
games in the college football playoffs
moving on with the story in QB 1 you win
the national championship of course sign
with a pro team and then make it to the
NFL but after making it to the NFL well
the game then in essence becomes the
standard franchise mode in part that's
because there are no more cinematic
cutscenes and telltale style choices
once you get to the NFL once you've made
it to the big time the narrative beats
play out through text messages you
received from fans and other players and
this delivery method makes conversations
feel awkward and ultimately forgettable
there's one storyline in particular
involving a sick child rooting for you
that ultimately falls flat while a
second major plot thread ends to
abruptly the single-player mode in
Madden 18 and 19 long shot took time to
cultivate its characters and this helped
foster the feeling of a personal
connection to their experiences but QB
one moves at such a fast pace that it
doesn't allow for thoughtful character
development QB 1 does succeed in
connecting you to your on-field
performance and inspiring you to improve
or play differently each week in some
ways this is achieved through a new
narrative system that provides you with
week to week objectives and challenges
that you can complete to earn XP that
can be invested back into growing your
character despite those positives the
story overall feels bare-bones and
incomplete leaving the entirety of the
QB 1
feeling like a half-baked idea you're
not getting an invite to the draft which
is a good thing I mean just ask Brady
right hey how's this I know a tailor and
he can make it feel like you're there
what's your vibe
madam twenties most exciting
introduction are the new X Factor and
super star abilities which provide the
game's most elite players with
game-changing special skills Aaron
Rodgers has the gambler X Factor ability
for example which makes it impossible
for AI defenders to intercept his passes
on the other side of the ball defensive
players like Stephon Gilmore and Aaron
Donald have abilities that can stop an
offense in its tracks
these x-factor abilities don't feel
gimmicky thankfully but cover star
Patrick mahomes currently feels too
overpowered he's going to take a shot at
the end
[Applause]
overall the x-factor abilities
introduced a level of strategy that the
Madden series has never seen nothing in
the updated gameplay mechanics for
Madden 20 is as substantial as the
introduction of real player motion from
last year but the controls in Madden 20
are as good as they've ever been thanks
to a further refinement on last year's
improvements in the introduction of some
welcomed tweaks and small changes the
game provides more on-screen info than
last year this makes it easier to see
things like decision-making specifics
such as average yards for play or yards
given up as well as which elite
offensive and defensive players have X
Factor and superstar abilities available
also new this year our run past options
that have been added to play books these
players provide yet another way for play
callers to mix things up and keep
defenders guessing you can also now
double press the receiver icon to
pump-fake this small change makes it
easier than ever to trick a defender
into biting on a pass route also notable
for Madden 20 is what's generally not
there bugs after spending many hours of
the game
I only experienced a handful of minor
glitches in my time with Matt in 20
however your mileage may vary madden 20
also looks very good with its better
looking player models that have richer
detail and more realistic flourishes the
madden 20 game engine also provides
gorgeous environmental effects like
glistening sun rays peeking through the
clouds and casting shadows on the field
as well as snow effects that limit your
vision and force you to consider playing
more conservatively the excellent
commentary team comprised of Brandon
Godin and charles davis also returned in
madden 20 and they are consistently a
treat to listen to with their dynamic
banter and informative yet entertaining
dial 50
kid he dives him to the end zone it gets
the two points madden 20 also brings
back madden ultimate team and this
fantasy team building card mode remains
the game's richest experience due to the
sheer number of challenges to take on in
the past madden ultimate team could feel
like a slog but a new mission system
helps streamline the experience the mode
still nudges you toward
microtransactions which may sour your
experience the standard franchise mode
in Madden NFL 20 in traduce --is a new
scenario engine that lets you interact
with coaches and players to take on
unique weekly challenges it's a smart
and fun way to make the long season feel
fresh and new every week however that's
the only significant addition for Madden
NFL 20s franchise mode this year and
that might upset seasoned players
wanting more overall Madden NFL 20 is an
improved and refined update on the
annualised pro football series the
lackluster qb1 mode is a disappointment
for those looking for a single-player
experience but the x-factor abilities
and improved overall gameplay mechanics
combine to make Madden NFL twenty one of
the best Madden games in a long time
[Applause]
to the races down
this one home it's a touchdown
part of what we just saw that's a great
example of
really amped up they put plans so well
yeah they didn't get overexcited and
have a best defense